[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
[Music]
your desecration of reality
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we can
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
[Music]
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie sadler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't
move bigger why do they always have to
go bigger
[Music]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline and the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
[Music]
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
there's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
haven't you ever wondered
what else is out there
[Music]
there's wonders in this world
beyond our wandering
[Music]
i can feel it
so
on game day it all comes down to heads
or
tails
see what we did there the showdown
begins
[Music]
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is your moment to be the big hero
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
sonic the hedgehog 2 april 8th
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse
and that man is my great great
grandfather great there's another great
grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move
yeah skin it again
[Music]
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
what's a bad miracle
we got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
my wife needs this surgery
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
i gotta get back to my life with my son
no matter what
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother
ambulance let me get everybody home
what is this taken am i talking
alan i'm here to save you
the key to finding the lost treasure
after them i am driving oh
getting you out of here why are you so
handsome my dad was a weatherman the
lost city march 25th
day and night
[Music]
[Music]
you